over the weekend Nancy Pelosi convinced
the president to call off his promised
removal of illegal immigrants who
refused to appear for deportation
despite outstanding court orders now
these are not people awaiting an
immigration or asylum hearing contrary
to what you think listening to speak no
truth Pelosi so when I spoke to the
president I said look I'm a mom I had
five kids seven nine grandchildren and
and your children are scared and I do
think that some of the faith-based
groups did weigh in with the president I
hope so and now we have to continue to
keep that pressure on note her typical
emotional ploy using children to get her
way except by the way when she wants
their lives ended well
no one wants any child ever to be afraid
ever it's tragic and it really shouldn't
happen in kids of American criminals
they suffer here too because of the
mistakes of their parents and parents
coming here illegally again tragic
now comes the consequences for the whole
family sometimes well at least there
should be consequences if the rule of
law means anything and by the way if we
really cared about kids what about some
of the stuff that's happening to
American kids those in the inner cities
in homeless shelters those with parents
addicted to opioids or kids themselves
who are addicts Nancy doesn't need to go
far does she from San Francisco to see
suffering and desperation we've seen all
those stories so maybe she should focus
on fixing that before throwing rocks
meanwhile her party rather than actually
working with the President to solve the
border crisis instead spends its time
sucking up to Planned Parenthood we need
to pass a federal law to make Roe versus
Wade the rule of women that are
incarcerated for undocumented immigrants
are that are incarcerated they deserve
to have access to healthcare because
healthcare is a human right no so let's
get straight they care so much about the
children that they're taking orders from
the organization that
this to destroy the children okay now as
for the resistance media who denied
there was a crisis all along just to
remember that they supposedly care about
children and everybody else more than
you do Mike Pence is lying about
children living in torturous positions
right they're allowing children to walk
around with lice and walk around without
diapers the wealthiest nation in the
world we have money to give toothpaste
and soap and blankets to these kids
given the sheer volume of families we're
talking about hundreds crossing at one
time in tens of thousands coming across
in one month just family units of course
a Border Patrol processing center will
be scrambling to keep up we saw it with
our own eyes and they're still doing
unbelievable work but awful situations
will arise but where were the Democrats
where was their outrage before Trump
came into office remember when the most
compassionate coolest president ever
said this do not send your children to
the borders if they do make it they'll
get sent back more importantly they may
not make it to demonstrate how woefully
dishonest and purposely misleading the
media have been on this issue of child
attention consider the finding made by
US District Court Judge dolly G an Obama
appointee from the Central District of
California
she found that migrant children had been
held in widespread deplorable conditions
and further the federal authorities had
wholly failed to provide the safe and
sanitary conditions required for
children even in temporary cells do you
know whom she was castigating there the
Obama administration yes it was Obama's
DHS that was supposedly running what
buffoonish Democrat radicals are now
calling concentration camps it's been
that way for a long time or something
and President Obama built the cages
President Obama built they call him jail
cells they were built
now do any of you remember Nancy Pelosi
firing off angry tweets and demanding a
change in Obama policy or criticizing
these allegedly income inhumane
conditions jeh Johnson was trying to
appeal that ruling remember and where
Hollywood starlets speaking out
no and no Trump has been trying to
manage this immigration disaster and
solvent that he inherited as president
but given the arbitrary rules laid down
by liberal judges his administration has
repeatedly asked Congress to fund more
beds for detention facilities they need
more money
guess what Congress refused and now they
blame him for the problem as he told
Chuck Todd doing a fantastic job under
the circumstances the Democrats aren't
even approving giving us money where is
the money
you know what the Democrats are holding
up the humanitarian aid and though the
president delayed his deportation plan
this weekend hoping that Congress would
work together and his words to work out
a solution to the asylum loophole
problems it's now increasingly clear
that this is not in the cards Pelosi in
a statement only agrees to spend your
tax dollars on the care and
transportation of the illegals and of
course don't forget the money to hire
lawyers for them to fight their
deportation where's the asylum fix
whereas the Flores Agreement effects
where's the TV PR affix these are quick
measures that the Congress can deal with
legislatively and the president is
asking them to do that
but it doesn't look like Pelosi is
interested in doing any of that
especially since Congress is only in
session until this Friday I love a
message for the administration in a bit
but don't be deceived by the media
coverage or the emotive images you're
seeing because it happened years ago and
the Democrats were silent the Democrats
want to eliminate all detentions and
these politicians corrupt lawyers
activists judges and NGOs will
characterize almost any holding facility
as a concentration camp
and then shut them down so no detentions
no deportations ever ultimately they
hope full vited voting rights for those
who came illegally end of story
plus he's not gonna end this crisis
she's cynically using the plight of
migrants most of whom have no valid
claim of asylum to full political
advantage and that's the angle